from two kings of Chess we get a near
perfect game with the pressure on
dingley Wren to win a game soon and down
one point against janapomnushy game 10
of the fide World Championship was
played with engine-like Precision from
both players each scoring over 99
accuracy according to chess.com's game
review on move 10 nepo played the
counter-intuitive King f8 giving up his
right to Castle he then sent his pawns
hurtling down the kingsign for an early
attack ding Perry this with a queen
trade on D6 allowing for a stable middle
game he should be confident about his
position highly accurate play from both
players continued into a rook end game
where ding was up two pawns but in the
end the old adage was true all Rook end
games are drawn I think that with a
smile gives it up he knows there's no
trying in this one with the
meticulousness rarely seen at the
highest level we were finally left with
only the Kings on the board and